Andrew you asked a question which
strikes fear in the heart of every
programmer and that is first of all
Moore's law which is held for 50 years
which says that computer power doubles
every 18 months may begin to expire in
the next 10 or so years in other words
if you knew that at Christmas time your
computer was just as powerful as the
last Christmas present
would you buy a computer would you
upgrade most people would say no why
should I buy a new computer if it's a
tentacle to last year's model well that
could create a planetary recession a
planetary depression knowing that this
engine of prosperity the computer
revolution is running out of steam but
that's just the way it is last month for
example I spoke in Zurich Switzerland I
met with the physicists at Zurich IBM
one of their leading institutions and
they told me that yeah they could see it
now it's not science fiction it's not in
the future they could see it now that
we're beginning to sputter with regards
to building more and more computer power
so some people are looking for a
replacement for silicon power for the
post silicon era
some people say quantum computers will
do it well yes in principle but quantum
computers require a totally different
architecture in a totally different way
of programming when you program a
computer you're basically telling one
CPU the Pentium chip how to process
information so you have a CPU with
inputs and outputs and then you have a
software that controls the CPU that's
called a Turing machine that's the basis
of what you have on your laptop which
you have in your cell phone all of it is
based on digital Turing type technology
but quantum computers are not quantum
computers compute on individual atoms
and instead of zeros and ones eros and
ones which are called bits we have
quantum bits or qubits that is sometimes
one sometimes zero sometimes any number
in between zero and one that's the
source of
power of quantum computers the fact that
you're no longer calculating on zeros
and ones but the problem with contemn
Peters is precisely because you are no
longer computing on zeros and ones how
do you program this thing it's very
difficult the way we do it today is with
an MRI machine we get a bunch of atoms
line them up put them in a magnetic
field
shoot electromagnetic radiation at it
from an MRI machine flip the charges so
one becomes 0 becomes 1/2 becomes 2/3
and then we measure the echo that's how
we do it today well the world's record
for a quantum computing calculation is
drumroll tada three times five is 15
that is the world's record for a quantum
computer calculation now you may say to
yourself well gee that's not such a big
deal well it is a big deal go home
tonight and try to multiply 3 times 5 is
equal to 15 on 5 atoms go home tonight
and try that and then you begin to
realize oh my god
this is really difficult difficult to
build also difficult to program what is
the problem with quantum computers
stability it turns out that interference
any kind of vibration will upset the
vibrations of these 5 atoms creating
nonsense so that's the fundamental
problem decoherence decoherence is the
reason why we cannot break codes with
quantum computers while you don't have
artificial intelligent machines as smart
as the human brain decoherence these
were atoms begin to decohere and turn
into a random jumble of atoms
just like the atoms in your body making
it useless so when might we have quantum
computers I don't know
but personally I think we'll have
molecular computers before we have
quantum computers that is we'll be able
to compute on molecules molecular
transistors already exist we can already
make them we can make them out of
graphene which is one layer of carbon in
a gigantic sheet the world's smallest
molecular transistor is one carbon at
that is a smallest molecular transistor
that we've been able to make so far so
personally I would bet that molecular
computers will replace silicon power
before quantum computers